it's just gonna go to us Rob it's all
good man it's not going anywhere else
hey guys sorry for the delay we had some
technical difficulties we had to swap
pcs because Rob pcs been possessed by
the dark side and they didn't want us to
play that's what I'm going with that's
why it's red over his head he looks so
stressed out man that was a little
stressful I don't get why I wasn't
working I mean it's a beta so you're
gonna have bugs plenty of them but we're
in it I don't know here we go
boom yeah I wish that it worked that way
but it doesn't
this is Battlefront 2 yep battle boy do
you see close but it's like early access
beta right so you would have had to
pre-order to be able to play either
yesterday and today and then open on all
the three big platforms that tomorrow
tomorrow till Sunday and then Monday we
get a last yet I trailer it's the Star
Wars weekend look at this did you get
crates good this looks cool actually
that's uh so this is what uncut uncommon
common epic and then there's legendary
okay so we're following the trend of
loot boxes and games hey continues I
just did Forza with Miguel and that also
has loot boxes so loot boxes the 2017
the Year loot box of you of loot boxes
Eric yeah yeah it's so cool
is it though no it's not you're not
liking it no I had we'll get into it
later but I had a little salty last
night and I'll get into it later okay
but let's just actually play because
lined yeah let's play a game
I'm I apologize I have to do one thing
do like to your sensitivity or invert
flight yet no you're an inverter well
for flight so there's one thing I will
say about this beta is that oh my god
why is always and you didn't didn't spaz
out for me last time
all right well controller support
controller support is has been weird
John Luke was having the same problem
with oh my god I hope it doesn't do this
while you're playing oh all right fine
now that's it
oh stop
I'm like one of the cables is loose yeah
well find out let's just get into one of
you you do me I do you all right just so
you guys know I'm here in the chat
looking out for you so if you got
questions concerns whatever I'll send
them over to Rob who's played I think
like eight hours is what your account
said so I'll say roughly eight it yeah
Luke Dunlap salty doesn't do it justice
oh we're gonna hear about the mines the
salt mines that he's been in so we'll
see a little more gameplay yeah thanks
so yeah yeah that one better than the CR
- oh my god it needs to stop doing that
it does it every time you change
something in the menus I don't know why
it's doing that
so yeah Eric there are star card star
cards Eric so I get these in loot
crate's get this I mean it's beta
granted yeah so whatever but uh yeah
star cards can be anything from an emote
to a AB damage buff a cool-down
shortener whatever you want to call it
it's do this and yeah yeah you get them
in a lot of assault yeah there we go
but there's one thing about this game
there is a card system says Bob Jones
yes yep sure there is
I mean compared to last game we all know
about those tokens you just picked up on
the field those power-ups so to speak
I'll take star cards I guess over those
because those are just completely random
what's up pelipper what is up Don Juan
it's like nineteen seventy six or seven
six six cyborg man the AC 280 with the
doubles Newman has the best loadout I
don't know we'll see what have you been
finding it's like you're damn my channel
I do like flying air but again
controller sport has been really finicky
just like that is a beta it is bad but
this we should kind of dice they have um
they have their betas at least don't
really offer a great controller sport so
it's kind of given like joysticks for
instance for like battlefield one
weren't really available until launch or
maybe even a few months afterwards God
roids joy to action here
super super okay you know what real
quickly Rob I'm gonna risk it because I
don't want that to happen to you again
once you try unplugging the HDMI and
plugging it back in or do you not want
to do that okay we're gonna take the
risk hopefully doesn't ruin everything
it might this has been the coolest
stream I love technical bronze do you I
don't know oh that was probably a poor
choice okay that's good I have to kill
it and open it again yeah seems about
right
this is not I would say this is mostly
not the game's fault this is our fault
so I want you guys to know that I will
take blame for it hashtag bow that's
know I'll take some blame no no it's my
fault
Saget Saget or says battlefront to has
actually already though it's like some
booths a lot more I agree it has
definitely improved all right going back
to game hoping that it doesn't happen
the way it did but we'll find out right
away let's also do one more thing
your dude oh no we're max now maybe
that's why you think so you think why
don't we set it to high case okay I'm
just gonna run it I know that quality is
not gonna show a dream that's why I'm
saying the show the Macari it's okay
this makes the show more endearing
Thanks that's a galactic assault you
know I'm having a good time yeah this
game we're playing on PC I got max
settings I have a lucky enough to have a
two game honor my desk now at home which
is always try switching like a gun
because that's what broke it right hey
oh no sniper oh we're good hey man you
gotta take it take the the plugs out
then plug it back in you know do we see
some officer game places mr. MacBride
okay you got it
you betcha gotta make sure my cards are
equipped though Eric also let's see what
this does
Oh what does it do ah voila you gained
that much health when you melee someone
sounds like apparently it's a good card
card epic but they don't really say that
it's just a farce interesting I know
right but yet like you said the color
scheme stuff like this yeah why not and
like even hearthstone where you kind of
have like a goes like white gem for like
calm in blue for like a rare purple for
an epic and then legendaries like orange
yeah alright this is where the real show
begins guys look this looks great though
look at all this dude it looks cool
foliage it's a spectacle right
it totally is a spectacle always been
the audio is better than ever the
graphics like the last game was so
gorgeous and they found a way to make it
even better here I think oh yeah oh so
I'm an officer
officers can right there I just gave
like a I think we can people around me
in a bit of a city get well a health
buff I think they take less damage I
think they get the output
how do you distinguish yourself as an
officer from these other guys I got a
yellow head a little yellow head there
that's like the originals - I see so one
of the things and I find it's a
frustrating mechanic but it's better
from the last one and the last one you
were kind of a lone wolf all the time
you didn't really do a lot of team play
which I think was a problem here they
they emphasized staying with your bugs
you see right before I join that's right
or right when I spawn I join up with
like three other guys we hang out
together we get more XP
however unlike battlefield one because
that will make that comparison
battlefield one puts you in an official
squad okay and they and your and your
teams are easily identifiable like
they're green even I think here it's
just random every time I spawn so you
never really get like a sense of I got
it like I I want to say like that a
strong group and like I wish you could
like call if someone could just like
call out any kind of like quick chat
like follow me or anything like that
because everyone just like a wheel like
a wheel chat or anything would be great
because it's kind of hard to like kind
of hard like know what everyone's
thinking you know like there's like so
many things well you have like one big
objective but it'd be nice to have more
team play around but okay or know that
you're gonna spawn with your other
teammates at like a board point where
like a safer put that exactly yeah and
the turret I can also detonate if I so
choose to Sam game over run alright
right now
Tanner Hartman wants to know how many
separate our options are there the
cycler rifle just didn't do it for me in
Battlefront one the options are specific
to class
whoa in this beta there's looks like
there's two weapon types for each class
at least so far that's so far there I
would be more I would be super so the
second one though
has these mod slots which is kind of
neat
however I'll get into it I'll explain
where my beef you're gonna go with no no
mod well I can't mod it yet I have to so
I have there's different types of
currency you gain the game there's
credits which you use for loot crate's
and then there are crafting parts which
I get from luke rates or from challenges
or if I get dupes with star cards I can
roll them or excuse me convert them into
crafting points I've yet to do that get
together do kit so that is interesting
just to kind of keep calling your point
about squads and teammates and things
like that because the tooltip there
itself said stay close to your teammates
that earn more points yeah I'm like well
how do you how do you distinguish that
as a player because on your screen your
allies are all blue examinee map so you
don't actually know like oh is this guy
like you have to almost like remember
okay who did I load in with you're
exactly right
that's that's another like problem with
that system is like I can't like you
know there are just a few moments yeah
they're gone I have no idea which ones
they are so it's like maybe it means
overall just be near your team okay like
an ad sponsor with your allies you're
good cuz you're an officer
I would hope yeah so like that move I
just did there you kind of saw that like
yellow line a stark card depicted we can
boost that vicinity they got an officer
over there saw them in a black suit
does your turret persist after death or
only while your I think it does oh good
night
alright sorry let me read some more
questions yes Gary Master Spin Master
stone we can totally do some space
battling after this oh you know it he's
all about space about it fight milk
wants to know hey Eric are the other
levels in the beta are there other
levels in the banner or just this one so
far yeah yeah no there's there's
galactic no start so this is black to
coffee yeah funk conquests on Naboo
there is Starfighter assault which is
over the planet fond or which sure but
like space battle but specifically for
Galactic this is the only bath correct
okay and then there is a new mode it's
like toned down just infantry 8v8 on
takodana oh oh I haven't flown this yet
do it okay so another question I think
someone asked are there still thermal
imploder 'he's 13 but that's probably a
star card okay might be a star card
cards are things you earn through loot
crate's of which if you're lucky there's
like various tiers of things if you're
super lucky you'll get the legendary
version which is like it's like a
percentage based thing where you know
your common version will have like a 5%
your legendary will have like
potentially 20% so I'm sure Raul's talk
more in depth about the loot system and
his thoughts on those excuse me I didn't
hit a building is it because you're on
the Nexus up there good night outside
anymore so they're like you don't need
to be blind or anymore you should be
doing this next objective also where the
hell am I put me on a weird spot I don't
know go find your yeah I guess you're
right but will keys have the thermal
imploder ziz what Jon are says okay and
Cyber Command has also seen thermal
imploder thanks guys appreciate you guys
yeah that had Robin some good knowledge
that a high beulah been a minute is
there a way to squat out with friends
have you have you played with anyone in
the office yet no that's good question I
think that's where it's at right like
yeah and I do see some cool teamwork
like you on an officer obviously too
like buff people you want oh hey oh it's
a wookie um you know betcha lists can
spot enemies a heavy has that let's
check that out actually I didn't play
much of it heavies have pretty cool good
thing you got some hot cards for some
reason all them we're playing on a
different computer so my star cards all
got white or not okay so you're with I
miss their names
cyborg man you can't have a start it
says the reason why you lost it is you
can't have a star fighter after phase 1
we check that make sense you can open
the next thing right so what's
interesting is like maybe it is that's
the case for the droids but like when I
play that III I was able to like still
fly the like and to boost our fighter
during this phase maybe I didn't it like
like I was your team yeah it was their
spawn points from outside but they
eventually everyone's inside a POC -
crazy 99 syc asking how did the gunplay
feel way better than the last game guns
are like very much unique and like they
like have more like different abilities
and stuff that goes more recoil and
different amounts I feel like for each
weapon and then the other cool thing is
the active reload date which is from the
last game it's more like pronounced here
we're like each getting it to engage Oh
sayonara all gasp
oh yeah baby come down - master 101 says
hi i sub thanks for subbing that's a
nice little reminder that we are alive
every day at 11:00 when we don't have
time to technical difficulties screaming
a bunch of different things so if you
haven't stopped already
you should sub to get notifications for
that and also we make a bunch of cool
features that you should check out
oh it's Arnold in Terminator
he's got the Gatling gun wait here and
then he like looks at a cool I'm
targeting all the legs don't kill anyone
you have sorry that casualties zero does
Darth Maul still wreck everything and
Bob Jones he does what scares me is that
so you can put cards on girl boba
yes but the Fett man dude I swear I saw
I'm gonna take all running that's sick
type all I could I could be clear let's
try this again ready oh yeah already got
to the chopped-up get to the contested
points when I say
yeah you don't want to come into this
yeah we done nope you guys have this on
lock look at how many droids are up in
this oh there's my ball round man
procedure round well I like to imagine
he actually was doing that I I do wish
there were more scenes of him not just
him but like you know how we're talking
about it the other day about just like
how crazy it was watching Vader just go
ham on some like rebel like commoners
it's always Jedi versus it just be sick
to see more of that to see more like yep
that's how powerful a Jedi is watch him
like mop the floor with a bunch of
people like that's awesome just kill
streaking yeah yeah I totally a great
thing you guys you kind of saw some of
that in like attack of the clones and
like the prequels a little bit against
roids but that's that's not the same
droids are like I don't I don't feel the
same when mace windu goes ham on some
more clones rather I guess
Oh Darth Maul go get him great this is
fast I can go oh oh my - how do you get
Darth Maul as Brent Collins it's like
you know it's you have to play it's a
it's a battle point system you have to
play well yeah and it's not like the old
way where you just pick something up off
the ground yeah and that's it's better
like it's kind of better like that no I
go back and forth man so like if you
want to play Darth Maul's you would want
have to play really well to not get any
other vehicle or any other of those
battle point unlocks and just save them
all until the last stage there so that's
kind of also like catered to the map
layout where like it goes from like
outside the inside so a lot of the chats
asking basically how have you messed
around a lot with the first person third
person thing so I've always heard that
like third person is the best way to
play and obviously you can like peek
around corners easy easier I want to say
you have more of like a wider
perspective but okay I will play the
person I prefer third person okay I just
hear that's always yeah I just I just
wanted to clarify for chat too and also
just make sure that like have you tried
that because some people are like oh why
is he not doing first-person and then
there's a lot of also people in chat
just mentioning how third-person lets
you see more which is what you said so
obviously a preference but they do want
to see some first-person also might yeah
I'll desperate gamer so yeah we can try
both obviously as someone mentioned it's
probably preference kind of thing how
you want to play it but it's cool that
has both actually I think you know I
think we've all seen so much of this
mode okay let's quickly go into the new
stuff okay as another question -
somebody asked it does each of the
classes have like a set have set
abilities or is it more tied to like the
cards I guess those are they're fairly
set classes I would say assault is just
your like your everyday man
heavy we saw that like this this is your
front line you can put up a shield you
use your heavy officer is your like
healer buff almost
I bet star cards will have more ability
so you can like as you progress you get
more star cards that do different things
so like you know and I still have to get
a third slot alright can I just say my
one gripe right now all right here we go
break it down I turn down the music a
little bit here come you you heard how
many hours tell me you got how many
hours do you think I played work oh it
said roughly on origin I think I said
like eight hours okay okay all
multiplayer by the way so I'll
multiplayer here's my currency here okay
these are crafting parts I finally have
120 I played eight hours and lives of
last night I had 40 no 80 I get a lot of
credits that I can get loot crate so I
can do this like every two matches my
issue that I find frustrating I hope
maybe they they allow you to get
crafting parts more often because I've
put so much time in now and I haven't
actually done any personal progression
so if you go into here and I take a look
at like this here like I can now finally
craft one one thing after that many
hours I can finally add one scope on to
something or I can get a weapon early I
believe that's really really slow and
it's and is there no other way currently
not that I know of
okay other than locking out.i bait I'm a
guy I may be wrong on this but like I
find that very frankly gross that like
yeah that like can you're forcing needs
yeah but you're like you're just you're
throwing so because I'm getting so many
loot crate's but they're all random but
you're putting so much of that in my
face because that we all know why you
wanted to just do that no
really okay but you're not like I'm just
saying because you just treasured those
I should I've been trying to just focus
on some but you get them saying yeah I
do
we're like the game is it doesn't
promote your ability to try other things
as frequently because you don't have the
scopes and you don't have a means to get
the mods as quickly as you need to in
terms of like trying to do what those
other things right but um that's your
experience so far and that does sound
like it's not very good obviously but I
want to know if there is a way that
maybe we don't know about that you could
get mods faster baby so I'll leave it
over to chat I don't know if you guys
are having the same problem in terms of
having enough parts to mod weapons but
Dillon I play Dillon H I pray to Orin
Jesus every day of my life okay
I play a game called destiny and I pray
every time I go to Rahul
he won't F me with a dupe exotic but he
does that anyways but um so maybe so
like I mean I guess well maybe those
crafting parts happen like this is all
early game right if this is how it's
gonna happen we're like okay I have to
be level 10 in order to get my third
card slot maybe once you know you put in
those 15 hours I don't know we start
getting more dupes and that's what
you're throwing back and you're getting
crafting parts more often then maybe
then maybe it's not that big a deal okay
I just in my 8 hours is like cool all
right which motor you finally put a
scope on um am I playing this is
first-person this is the talk of Donna
Mazdas castle we all know it's sick yeah
yeah but bounty hunter I'm dying now
this one's flanking you guys but this is
like a kinda like what does this modem
call it's called strike but it's I were
to say anything it's like arm like like
leave it like arm the bomb type of thing
so like like I think we're tasked with
picking up data and then gotcha
and then running it from A to B what's
up who g7 welcome to the chat
cyborg man basically saying yeah to get
parts is really up to loot boxes that's
kind of scary then they solu boxes will
also just give you parts yeah but that's
what he's saying though like yeah you're
pretty much like hoping to get parts in
a loop it's rather just kind of sounds
scary
if you know there's an alternate means
to getting that faster but you show
you're getting like to loot boxes per
match or sorry for too much right oh
okay having played first-person alright
we'll do one more round of first-person
then we'll show you the power of his
third person it's which is kind of weak
still better than probably though yeah
anyways yeah that's just my a little my
little oh that's a pretty big that's a
pretty big problem though I think so
because like I said you can't really
then you really have to think about what
you're gonna put a scope honored you
know yeah what on because like Walt
there goes a hundred parts I don't know
when I'm gonna get another hundred
I mean it's but it's like it's like it's
kind of blocking the core essence of
like a multiplayer shooter or any game
really any kind of like you know it's
it's an inherent progression system that
should be present in any of those games
yeah that's me any game like needs a
habit if you're limiting my my [ __ ]
should just chance and like want me to
just enjoy just like the one I had yeah
me with it yeah I think it's that second
ability I like have this like one
ability I think I have it equipped that
like turns it into it what's up John
crack glad you had a bunch of fun
playing the beta yesterday and thanks
for tuning in
Oh feels bad here's the act of reload
rag doll up thermal detonator there it
is guys man that's that sucked you got
two guys so we'll like one hell all
right that's it here we go
serious business mode fire thousands of
crazily enough cotton fields maybe if
you had a lot of money
oh I killed him down so that's cool
thanks
but Eric this game looks amazing no
that's great I think that the sound
design I mean like as good as bow
Battlefront one obviously but oh the
sound design I think is yeah it here is
I think oh oh my god they're coming hi
they're coming in hot and heavy dude in
this one like I think they had a little
bit in the last game with like mud on
like your armor and stuff but it's like
full-on like I've been like a pristine
white stormtrooper and then like five
minutes later I'm just comfortable
damaged or like are we gonna do a loop
box screen maybe on this day oh God
people love that's gonna make me so
upset though oh why think it's awesome
because you get all of it dude you're
getting surrounded and strange classes
you're on the wrong side in this fight
we are rapid KUB
although are you oh this is a resistance
force neutral yeah go figure
guys can you inspect your weapon we can
do it later what was the weapon someone
was saying was good the one you just put
your scope on the a2/ad I think Oh with
the I think someone said a 280 with a
dual zoom scope or something look at
duck HD look at him Superman eh yeah Oh
am i get a loot crate soon dude oh yeah
yeah you get it is it like overwatch
where you get it every time you level
probably so you have Luke rapes that are
specific to you a class a bunch of stuff
okay like I got like I play I flew a lot
of ships and I got a star fighter Luke
rape and it's like guaranteed one star
fighter item what do you get from these
challenges
probably a loot crate thanks so yeah I
mean that's another thing it's like I
don't know like I hope launch the launch
game has like a bunch of challenges and
means of like getting [ __ ] but I just
feel like I was not getting [ __ ] anyways
like I looks hot look how hot that is
it's not someone kill you with the f11 D
that first got me yeah so I saw a
player's name was like FN like 209 nice
the guy was in character but uh oh
there's a sniper variant called the AC
280 I don't think that's the same gunman
I probably misspoke oh that looks sick
yeah that's just for look though no
that's well that's from the movie no I
know but that's like buying that would
be purely for aesthetics no that was a
that's like a Darth Maul very okay flame
thrower like a hero yeah there's like
there's like rocket jumpers did you
clean though you will wrapping around oh
yeah feel barrel roll I have no idea
what this is I just did
nice good reload show yourself
resistance gum
oh yeah I guess I guess I should hang
out with my team right yeah I guess so
let's try this shotgun oh yeah oh no oh
no damn look at my muddy boots like you
want a shotgun too bad all right
there's we can't play story mode yet
Darth tread on Trey thon hmm there's a
single player oh it's just multiplayer
beta I thought you were like naming a
Star Wars planet yeah he played heavy
class earlier Hawk I'll play it again uh
maybe I'll play better with it oh shoot
are they up top I feel like this oh you
get a roll I saw the rocket okay as an
aid oh yeah oh look down there yeah
that's that's a good that was going now
I'm all muddy look at all muddy oh nice
oh look at them hiding in a little
corner that's a good spot yeah let's try
heavy all right heavy we go what okay
cool I got all my cards in jenk I love
in the combat role yeah that's that's a
big deal yeah you gotta be rolling
during look like what no no no of how
you're shooting no right oh yeah you can
hey we're doing a test we're gonna get
something out oh oh there's a shield of
my gun I should use that's what happens
when you don't play a class too much
what's your favorite class so far says
Robert asked Robert Upson his name's
Robert yeah Robert what's up
[Music]
heavy is pretty sick we're trying to
diversify here in the office folios yeah
but uh but uh I've been playing a lot of
specialists who's kind of like that
sniper like specialists speaking like
spot enemies and stuff probably the
shield is that you're slow I'm slow as
[ __ ] yeah activate its cooldown Oh what
that was weird
I guess I spawned on you oh he's in the
cockpit where were you behind me yeah
yeah I did nothing - we're not trying to
be funny but thanks when she stole
gaming what was fine I don't know he
said we aren't that funny but I don't
think either of us made a joke Wow and
you guys aren't funny
No
Oh what where did that guy come from
Oh dirty I am dude that how sick is that
I hate when people get stuff before me
well you can pre-order the game then
cancel your pre-order
I would not recommend that I don't I
don't think it works oh I don't well I
don't think it works during well mushy
you can play it tomorrow it's a open
beta tomorrow yeah so everyone gets to
play it this weekend but I guess his
argument was that he didn't like that we
got it first
Oh which is fair i mean i pre-ordered it
it wasn't necessarily like we got it
first cannot unsee the money starting to
purr oh oh whoa you must not have known
you knew I know pick up the artifact
oh he's a shot forest I saw you well you
look real weird Oh
slow slow warmup you try to go to that
Gatling yeah I really want to see more
maps this one looks pretty damn good I
like it I kind of like it
or I like this mode in general too
it's like toned back oh sure
dan like this Rob he's also reloading oh
three swings later he was afraid he was
afraid I was intimidating he was
probably like oh [ __ ] I can't reload my
gun he's attacking me uh sorry I forgot
the name of the map I just know this is
where Mazdas castles yeah exa Dona
[Music]
pitbull 2304 open beta tomorrow still
early access beta today someone on
reddit pointed out the million Falcon
over there and even they like the detail
in this game man it's insane
there's like a in the remember in force
awakens when they did they killed the
engines on jakku and like a shot it with
the locks to turret they like took that
shot and there's like a there's like a
right there that like um that laser burn
is like put on there I know it's just
kind of cool that they totally like get
to go all out I bet that is so fun for
people like developers
seriously so they're a lot of work to do
err I'm not that good this it's all good
I want to see this guy
yeah oh interpret just so you guys know
the game actually releases November some
dirt site October 17 take it that right
no vet November November I had it right
the first time
November 7 and they're everywhere are
their squads not really holster this is
kind of how it works but I hope they
have locked squads like but you want
something closer to Battlefield one
right mm-hm
where or like a lot of or battlefield in
general is known for that like they they
automatically like put you in a spot
sighs mom vilest will do some space
fighting soon I wanted to see TIE
fighter oh I would love to show that
then we'll do star fighter them both
after this throw your cell you stand
oh they're just asking for trouble Robin
ice killing the first guy stretch
specialist November 17th we're getting
released actual release attack them from
behind we could try it John J Davison Oh
9 1 I mean squads in they like sense
that like I don't know you can't it's
not like battlefield where like it's
like I want to spawn on my squad there
isn't that right it's no randoms just
puts you together oh I hear what it is
yeah no I wish there was that even cuz
I'm then I'm like you know assuming
that's what they mean in chat that's
what I'm officer got you back I'm moving
around so you notice like the kill like
showed what star cards he had yes that's
what scares me to is to like see
someone's star cards and he has like all
legendaries mmm just be like great well
yeah that's the that's the argument
right it's like okay some of these are
damage modifiers on like how much damage
you do right like it give me a 5%
increase a 10% increase up to
potentially a 20% increase so it's like
when you're having these want like a
potential one-on-one duel with somebody
did they win because of the star card
did they win because of skill right
that's kind of where it gets a little
[Music]
worrisome I guess yeah but the other
thing that I think frustrating is that
but moving legendary star cards the
highest star card you could get you can
only get in the loot crate so what so
what I could also do with crafting is I
can take like an uncommon and put
crafting into it and make it a comic up
until epic where that's where stops and
then I just have to look out on Luke
rates and get like a cool item for my
favorite class in a specific abilities
it was like
and in that walkie Camaro
oh I didn't kill him oh I backed off I
didn't kill him
am i playing okay warmup what happens
when you don't warm it up we're warming
up right now we're up with cat what's up
chat so [ __ ] yep and coat man that
mong-joon dark talking about that hot
and mud on the boots or on the armor
yeah it looks so good the sound effects
for the starships are so tight the
hopefully we I mean even just see Boba
Fett's seismic charge remember from
Attack of the Clones where it's just
like this sound deafening boom it's so
freakin cool doesn't that person know I
died got the flame oh they flash me
great
leave that that rocket booster huh Oh
God it's got so much armor Rob it's a
Wookiee oh you just don't care oh so
noscope you that's whatever sin Oh
[Music]
rocket trooper sure sure we're flame
trooper flame rookies can roll that's
pretty good wookies can roll so devil I
mean anyone can roll yeah
Moomin was saying that he plays he
personally plays better in first-person
some people said that and other people
said I believe it more precise and more
for them oh that's not good
please come closer
I didn't even reach that far Rob no no I
don't really like I've never used this
guy he's got to be a game type where
he's got to go be able to inside or
those corridors you always see me
looking fine to just you gotta flank um
and don't put the flames on it until you
get like real close to them and then you
got a barbecue have yourself an
old-fashioned stormtrooper Barbara Oh
Zach is that a wookie it is Oh fun
one kill worth 100% worth I'm not gonna
talk too much about three what you're
mentioning there Tyler I feel our hearts
and our prayers are out for the people
that were affected in the Las Vegas
shooting yeah there's a terrible events
you get dirty here just mainly your
boots oh no you can get full on muddy
Lee Cummins wants to know hey guys you
know if there's a limit to heroes and
special classes like in the originals
there could only be maybe four jet
trooper players etc and there can only
be one hero per team
say that again he said do you know if
there is a limit to heroes and special
classes like in the originals there
could only maybe be your jet trooper
players etc and the Ryan v1 here so the
to my understanding the yeah this still
the same son what in that heroes and
hero ships yeah you can only be have one
on the field and that guy took all of
them well that always happens whoever
got yeah whoever got first gets all like
the credit for each but the other games
there it wasn't like that
oh okay but um
alright time first where Rob shines
hopefully what was I say oh yeah but the
i would i think the like the rocket
jumper and like a wookie and the kind of
lesser heroes if you will like the
stronger classes those I don't think
having necessarily like a fat get more
crate let's try this out dude
do I have enough Oh Eric I have enough
this is so fun hey you earned some a
good amount though from play awesome
saying you get credits you open a lot of
blue crates dude whoo that one looks
like a like a tier 3 oh just kidding
and I don't know we don't need it's a
common ship in the star photo oh that's
good 20 parts is that like considered a
lot is 20 a lot there or sure are you
looking for like you're a little short
it's an allegiance paid 20 is I mean you
saw a hundred seems to be like the
minimum what's the most you've ever got
oh oh how many elbow hurts it is that
what kind of tear is that oh [ __ ] is
that legendary yeah oh [ __ ] death from
above first legendary tell if it was her
the coloring is not obvious I don't even
know what color that was why did I
suddenly see Duggan okay I think revamp
maybe James Duggan oh [ __ ]
Duggan Duggan aka IGN oh man he just you
just went to town on us what if they're
live too man
that's cool okay that's sick
oh that's cool let's let's go find you
and use this death from above move let's
let's make sure we have that these are
my hero okay
my hero cards dude the FET man oh man
can we get some Fett action later I need
some Fett action in my life all right
let's get to it
yeah it's baited and it will wipe but
still feels good to get out legendary
you know wait is that really was that
really James Duggan I don't know that's
what um
so Ben Jacob who used to work at IGN who
now works for Games Bob so da said that
that he thinks that that's James Duggan
Aaron so so so this is not a stream
sponsored thing at all if you missed it
already
Rob his giving his one big salty gripe
and that was about gear parts and the
lack thereof let's see how long your
like seven you're like at seven hundred
credits we played like two or three
games you got to 2100 and then you only
got 21 24 it's so like maybe like
averaging like every ten games or
something you're getting like 100 parts
maybe I mean if I play you know you know
what if it's just because I suck no but
that end adds nothing to do why you
think you get more credits for playing
better yeah I would imagine
well we're experienced this mode is
pretty fun I do like it this is a huge
step up from the last game in that if so
many things flying is now one-to-one so
you can actually manual roll so it's
like you're actually flying something
it's a Starfighter assault right yeah so
yes Macari this is where you only fly
ships okay guy for my star cards ah yeah
get that tactical jammer it was the one
I wanted damn you got some comments what
a scrub I am so sorry that's fine what
is a scans always I have no idea if
they're gonna add more stuff throughout
this beta
I know cod was doing that where they
kind of unlocked more classes like on
the weekend or like they unlock more
tiers of stuff but hardly say now have
to max we're currently playing on PC as
you can kind of see in that FPS counter
in the bottom right we that was
intentional why don't you you should
just have yeah oh that's kind of cool
though so like it shares cards for both
sides it's not like a specific like to
this ship to the ship yeah I mean that's
convenience so if I were to play
Imperial yeah but what it like what if
it was yeah but that would be
all right here we go look at that hot
it's pretty hot controller sensitivities
alright that's fine like they have
bombers now it's like I need you to get
the Millennium Falcon due to health that
I want the slave one it's got the best
sound effects I remember I did I did
like a stream with you where you're
doing I feel like it was the stream and
you're doing work with the slave one
that or I just remember watching a lot
of you owning in the slave one and that
was felt yeah you are like in the last
game he like so now you have like all
these like things you can fly into and
objectives poses just deathmatch in like
an area with like no obstacles which
makes dogfighting really bored now I can
like so many times I've like flown into
this like ship and like this giant
station and like did sick maneuvers and
like was able to uh did you ever unless
you're going down Ram yourself into the
ship
oh I've crashed many times it's it's
it's definitely happened on the other
end where I like pursuit someone and he
like to the stick move that's that was
so cool
saying that sound as you bye
and get such great spectacles like it's
it is so aesthetically oh so I have an
r2 unit now I use it a little early you
not fly into the quite too hard at that
point to fly into this ship right that's
coverage yeah right you want to be able
to else try out the ailing anyway it's a
little weak it's got the speed though
maybe a speed or you just take out a
type okay no yeah that's thing too is
you you can do a lot of different things
like and it looks like you have missiles
and bomb and you really are pilot I
would have crash oh I like all that
damage on it no right just looks so good
know what really riles Rob up fellows
where's red leader
oh it's just so overly sensitive oh yeah
you can't get away tk5 five six yeah
we're gonna get out of there
hello I just subscribe hi Kaler Hudler
to three to four thank you for the sub
thanks for tuning in thanks to all of
you oh here we go
so eventually we have to I don't even
know why I should be in here oh wait so
now we do perfect
good timing you oh yeah see this is when
you want that a wing for that
maneuverability all the ships can
actually like they have a pretty good
turn oh hey buddy bit a little y-wing
just need another bill they have it like
Auto locks on and also does like think
it's a damage boost
you can't crash into your allies you
know what's also great is they they
toned that back in the last game I felt
like I was always like just you're just
constantly running into people and
blowing up immediately here you do take
some damage
dang those things have a lot life
[Music]
why would you do it there Bob jobs but
you fly as a y-wing now hey guys
Elite Z saying tomorrow is open for
everyone at 4 a.m. Eastern which is
roughly on par with what it was for the
three early access I think was 1:00 a.m.
right was when he could start pre
loading and playing yeah so hopefully
you guys get a chance to get into the
open beta and fire oh generator damn
first personal you are you getting
playing the objective yeah like that
[ __ ] oh yeah I like that [ __ ] are you
gonna crash because of it though oh one
more that you gotta go
that was real yeah that was closest but
maybe I know he didn't know that you're
gonna be a wild card
real wild card maneuver what I would do
those hatchet arias what I would suggest
though it's like yeah you might not be
up at 1:00 a.m. Pacific or 4:00 a.m.
Eastern but you should definitely at
least get your preload going so that you
know when you wake up and start gaming
right away feels bad when you wake up
and you're just staring at a download
bar you're like man I wish I could be
playing this game oh it's a center oh
man to tie interceptors cellphones -
laughing I like wow you know what when I
was first a Star Wars fan I used to love
the wily now I've done as much they're
so slow this is cool though it has a
really cool kind of like special feature
the ion cannon on the top oh you guys
ion cannons are like you know they're
like shield sailors and like you know
they'll fry your circuits more or less
right I can just auto turn it on so
there and I'll just shoot so if
someone's on myself oh that's pretty yes
it's pretty awesome Millennium Falcon
play so someone's on my six oh good
we're like a freaking van driving it out
on the Autobahn minivan mega fun r2 are
used are to already know I got you're so
slow that's problem
yep as mentioned it should be on origin
at 1:00 a.m. Pacific or 4:00 a.m.
Eastern so you should be able to pick it
up then when the open beta starts
warrior streak says amazing graphics I
agree with him god it looks so big dude
oh my god like again I have it we have a
2k monitor I have one at my desk
God it looks some everyone like everyone
office walks by is like
this is pretty cool though last thing is
the last game like they kind of I feel
like the star fighter mode was an
afterthought I mean granted snow
Battlefront original battlefront 2 where
you go like oh you could like suck it
poured chips and stuff that would be
amazing
but at least now you could fly in ships
no sorry but smart Matt Marcel said why
the why wing is the Honda Odyssey of the
Star Wars you do it guess what guess
what hot and hot at Honda Odyssey oh
yeah for like yeah like most my life I
drove it took a crime muffled no wonder
you don't want it why why waiting
anymore yeah my friend just got one too
which is he's solid car that's all a car
sounds bad
the only thing I hate about it was a
heavy look electric doors I would were
such a pain the ass cuz he had had to
have the car in park so all my friends
would just turn it on as a joke cuz then
I had to put the car in park for us to
stop the basically and stop the beeping
thank God that was bad person wants to
know how is there explosion into place
there's no that's such a tired point oh
you can't hear sound it's funny I just
did it to taking her life if there
wasn't sound or explosions in space it
beep star wars wouldn't exist
oh you didn't even need to do that I
know he's got this wait why is he
turning
it's funny too because someone told you
to pull up their philanthropy aka Ben
chenkin office says I think that they
were part of my favorite part of this
stream is just how excited Rob is about
everything I just you know when I
crashed just now I just wanted to show
what that looked like
got it so play are the Imperial side are
you just defending the ships then yeah
and you've taken out blockade runners
there's a lot like that's what schools
like these these modes have a lot to do
opposed to like daily challenges refresh
daily or sorry they're not daily
challenges I do these challenges okay I
hope they will they're not right now oh
I do not want to quit things first and
then we got got a slave one right you're
gonna be and then get the slave one I'll
try it my best make sure my store cards
are home was there good relook in
cockpit view in the last game I can't
remember you have a free look at the car
yeah I can remember the last game I it
doesn't look like it in this game or in
this beta that would be neat you know
what I did do for a little bit was turn
off HUD actually it turns off the
crosshair and actually was doing okay
surprisingly but it looks it looks
really cool when you do it is still in
destiny mode yeah sure that's correct
you know apparently that's an elephant
scream reverse hello credo says man they
improved flying so much yeah it totally
did
honestly the your only gripe the
sensitivity right now it's the
controller and again like that's kind of
like with these banners like they didn't
they haven't like optimized yeah
controller support yet because
apparently gentle trying to play just
like infantry with the controller and it
was he said it was the same exact things
just like super
like overly sensitive and like kind of
jerky
were you like you're just you can't get
the the precise adjustments even if I
tampered with the settings oh my god but
I wasn't oh you didn't pick your is that
was dumb
yeah like there's no more Auto rule so
like the biggest gripe the last game is
when I do a full flip I'll be upside
down the game with Auto roll for me
and and it's just coming in hot Rob this
is not working oh it's not so good and
that's the coolest they added that like
that speed boost it just looks and
sounds so cool in a shockwave sorry I
like turned it up so much that probably
drowned you out also my teammates must
hate me the hell's like I doing
[Music]
I turn it back that way
4:00 a.m. tomorrow would be roughly 16
hours from now
warriors stake I'm not sure when you'll
get your coat if you ordered one problem
I have is the locking is rough it like
it's not very intuitive like I can't
like pick where I want to lock it like
like say it will just auto lock onto
something like closest to me or like a
post like no I want to lock on to this
blockade runner this tie fighters are
really different
you got this how how can you got how can
you do this better and you didn't kill
me but I just like it just like
eliminates such Oh what okay okay get
out of it well you got that one
no I don't like it yeah I can see why
you don't like it now
and maybe you switched to it when you're
in pursuit but even then I don't know
what you got you gotta zoom in what
already okay they totally pull from rug
one which is great
remember that when Vader shows up what
is uh what's his star it's got a sick
name furs maybe Chatwood know what Darth
Vader's Star Destroyers names
what is Darth Vader's star stores like I
could look about probably I have a
computer it's like our start with an R
or D like Devastator Oh got it
or wait change the mode says Felipe we
got a cater to everybody I wanted space
that's it how about just one more or no
it's the executor no the executor is
executors executors executors is that's
his command ship that's super
stardestroyer is the executor don't
destroy so it is Devastator then yeah
the Devastator is mine and those who
oppose me will meet a swift and dark
chaos
sick sick yes the Devastator was an
imperial living either IRL class star
destroyer of the imperial navy famous
for its participation in the capture of
tan 2 for 10 to 4 that's less the new
hope yes Darth Vader's flagship for a
time so there you go the Devastator it's
it's and it's the one that in rogue one
when he rolls up and just destroys like
a transport whoa Dillon calm it down
there all right I already know I got
this but you know what's the funny thing
about this mode 2 especially with that
system of like you know stay close to
your friends you'll do more experiment
works perience yeah yeah and this in
this mode sure I mean it'd be great but
like this mode even you know flying
requires even more attention to like see
where my teammates are Reese's Pieces we
will do some galactic assault in a
little bit but there was also some
people that wanted to check out the
Starfighter assault so we're gonna do
this for like
another like pool round I guess you're
playing as the rebel I mean the last the
last one was just so short I need some
more type lighter action I know I kind
of agree I could I could boot out no no
let's just finish this round off and
we'll maybe play some love play some
girls relaxed ik assaults yeah I'd like
to show more of that modes they did add
Boba Fett legendary man alright
you sound so excited that's excited I
know I'm I am I'm excited I'm excited I
got it necessarily it's like just never
get it I mean the chance of getting a
hero at least for me
Oh
yeah
oh I got you bud whoa that you just fly
chase blue into the enemy : oh what a
dominant hey he didn't want to give you
the satisfaction that's their console hi
it's way too early to tell on that front
especially now having a single player in
this game we'll have to see how that
shakes out
now I had Auto roll on actually not that
bad though
so apparently criterion death company
did the flight work the flight controls
because people know about the x-wing
mission from the VR the b-raf guess
pro-1 yeah they like reworked the
controls for that just that one kind of
demo and it was great it was like super
well done and very much like you made it
here I feel like Steven Walker the open
beta will be for everyone has opened it
up so check that out for AMD Sherwin and
Pacific there's a question here Reese's
Pieces asking games well what is your
favorite arrows I'll let Rob really
handle this one yeah it's probably
whispering namely return the Jedi is
like my personal theory but the fresh
Strikes Back is the best
that's you know my favorite way what
attack of the clones but that's a mess
that's fine dude this kid do the pod
racing scene is so good barrold that's a
cool trick
how are you playing as Oprah sees we're
playing the early access beta so if you
pre-ordered the game you had access as
of yesterday today is still early access
day until tomorrow which is open captain
that cate-cate lad Kaka
this is so Purdy yeah looks pretty good
it's just in why I want to chart while
exam or no this the Honda Odyssey
Odyssey
okay kids do you think there's any
chance that they'll add podracing why
not right no how was then it's not
really like a conflict oh oh oh that's
it
do what is that sighs that's a seismic
charge that just kills all audio for
everyone it's amazing
oh come on Millennium Falcon hunt him
down you like to just like run into
somebody else take care of him Oh
brilliant
where was he I want to hear his seismic
charges kanon-chan says Return of the
Jedi but Strikes Back is great two
strikes back for Swiss Guard
I watched her turn a Jedi last night
oh yeah yeah it's it's this game and
then the trailer supposably oh X stark
malls interceptor things called Snyder
oh you got him though did I kill him
yeah you did
straight up well I mean maybe with help
but took them all from the shake and
bake with the Odyssey spaceman kids hold
on okay shocker kids we're gonna be late
to practice
I'm sorry for commands that Boba Fett
chickened out that's right we won the
the chicken you can do it he did check
it out actually review that footage he
definitely chickened out right nap my
car's worth - worth my stations work too
much see ya to be completely honest I
was dead set haha like I would would
have been happy with running and
Matthias pot Hoff wants to know how many
medical ourian's you have I bet there's
a website that would do that I mean and
again all it says is like zero it's just
like every person who asks it's like
zero to comment how many did Anakin has
did they actually show a number I don't
know God did that all right I guess I
could
how many medical
did they show what they like look it's
one of the first searches the second
search is a loop all the important
questions what is Luke Skywalker's medal
oh yeah give me that list Anakin
there's a ballpark number of over 20,000
damn oh look who it is
Yoda would be second what oh because he
says that not even Yoda has a medical
Orion count that high so in the chat
asked it just joined asked are there
tokens no they're no longer tokens
unless the clip that I gave you in like
the conquest modes you accumulate battle
points so if you like perform well then
you can get into like exponentially
better stuff ending in ending at like a
hero
starting with life
yeah get rid of that hopefully well the
one bro wind has come out November 17th
officially open beta this weekend though
so if you want to try it out give that a
go do it say my buddy get off some of
the cool cats Oh get away this that's
like whoa the what's another van that I
could call that type offer something
Astro what's a Toyota Sienna see it
Toyota Sienna yeah stay on him come on
Sagittarius please don't get caught
playing games your teachers gonna blame
me and Rob and I don't want that that
burden who shot who shot us
are you watching Star Wars you can't
play as a b-wing currently right oh god
I wish there's the no Corinne okok it
may be later was there
what's the special x-wing its Poe
Dameron dude the house and that's such a
smart move or how they like what they
did with the x-wing the new x-wing wings
is like made him flush opposed to like
stacking they like they like fit
together it's so cool oh there's the
boat there's the boy slave I want to
hear him do a seismic charge yeah I want
him to do it on my face I think this
sounds so cool this is that awesome tell
me that's awesome that's pretty awesome
oh he's dead already
oh we've got Darth Maul no I didn't I
got it killed you just now you gotta get
dark there's a lot of action going on
here dang this type armor is giving you
the shakes
but like in the a wing a lot serious is
the teacher now he's right on cop it
view you got it you got it Phil Elliott
the one says this looks amazing
I'll do one better what's that no HUD
this man's a wild a wild child here
there's a near miss Rob where's Lee
maybe hopefully uh-oh on release I can
release have like a this looks pretty
sweet though
I know right he could play we play like
no problem there was no there was no
getting out I wasn't clear I thought I
was in the clear
[Laughter]
Ramu Sood says I have to save my money
for destiny 2pz that's a good point
comes out October 24th arrests in pieces
that's like such a that's always a funny
thing to do it's like when you when you
engage like in Grand Theft Auto like
cinematic mode like how far could you
get like going like 150 miles an hour
alright enough of that huh Oh rank tank
though that's good that means you can do
your third card now right on all your
stuff you know what I think you're right
she saw I'm coming I kind of did myself
yo nice crash by the way thanks man
it was it was a good and then all of a
sudden oh crap that's a ship and we're
not avoiding that you know what I was
trying to mimic was in return of Jedi
when the a wing crashed into the super
star destroyers like the bridge and then
took it down but then really have
cockpit harder to aim uh-huh
you know I should probably turn back on
is apologies
Oh yep what nothing you know I feel like
doing I'll see if I can open up some
more crates dude all right let's see no
so fun definitely can okay you did not
get very many points from doing that
couple matches yeah I think you're right
all right all right on here galactic I
thought you could do split-screen co-op
in this galactic no this in this beta oh
this beta can you got what arcade
campaign
not one player no maybe it's on the
weekend maybe open beta I know uh Dave
and Oscar who went saw in the UK they
were able to yeah if you haven't seen
any of that stuff Dave from the UK's as
Rob just mentioned did get us some cool
capture of various modes so that's all
on our YouTube channel hi Carlos
alright demand some boba fett I demand
you play so good you got our pressure
that we get the Fett man this is a cool
I wanna show that off okay let's do this
ready Freddy
does it
here we go see if I can pull this off
whoa damn but what yet scared me you got
infiltrated all right that's fine battle
droids blend in pretty well in this map
do you feel like battlefront 2 is gonna
I mean we obviously haven't seen enough
single-player but do you think it's
gonna be like titanfall 2 as as it was
10 fall 1 or titanfall or do you think
that back after that jumps not as big no
I don't think that but I know you guys
are at least interested in like dude the
single-player is looking really good I'm
actually like I think I'm more excited
for that than this multiplayer I like
that last animatic last cinematic they
had was really promising the conflicts
like it's just the plot of it like but
your daddy just goes to you by the way
Brian folklore and volgar there won't be
split-screen we have some sweet footage
up actually so if you want to check that
out yeah it's I believe it's very
similar to the last game which is like
you do like kind of like Arkady
challenges split-screen
I think that's about it
what Excel Losos watch out I live oh
it's another guy droid party here you
focus and we're talking just killing
sore slang I don't know
destroying robots
so gams dad says it's only in arcade
mode which yeah we could definitely do
not have Long's and what if we can see
there
oh this other I'm not using it this is a
ability I swapped out for what you do
she has me where dudes are they what a
hacker one guy that's all Cho they're
all going left Rob
there are jetpacks right Bill Elliott
asking we could see jetpacks mccurry
yeah they're they're like you have to
use the battle point system to get to
that meaning I have to like rack rack up
like a handful of forints before I can
engage it that guy's dynamism all the
stupid [ __ ]
he had that guy need a 150 damage oh
nice
oh so close those doesn't really good
spot though oh I can fly this these are
new sure you don't allow me to no I'll
wait I'll save do what do you you do you
oh wait okay I kind of want but that was
the problem too that Nick was saying
like he was waiting forever on his place
to try to get a gyro but then someone
else would beat him to it so it's like
only one Darth Maul can be in the map
Darth Maul I am the Fett man though be
out at the same time
sure well two heroes cuz you have to to
choose from for the most part only well
that's beta at least but yeah I'm pretty
sure you could have two at a time just
not the same you know you can't have
twins Road Road Amran saying that you
can play arcade mode you're just already
joining an online game when you tried to
alright oh god where are you at we could
try that
oh yeah we gonna to your left to my left
I just see a lot of like red markers on
your lap like behind you now Oh
automatic yes Bill Elliott there's
active reload which is more pronounced
in this game yeah mentions like unique
they're more unique to like each weapon
as far as like you know the kind of the
mini game if you will that you're yeah
yeah it's nice
this is big this oh my god nope oh that
thing of course MTT no way
whoops
what
oh my god we could potentially try out
arcade oh I killed me mr. dameran we'll
see though yeah we'll see he's saving up
his points for the the hero cards
hopefully I'm not gonna get it now with
that attitude that's for sure you're
right can you play a first person please
give you a little bit
he likes third-person Marvo will give
you a little little taste
and then even the audio you hear is
breathing it Morris I was just about to
say the ass god boom that takes a while
what the load waiting for like a squad
to fill like I think it should be
quicker or I can just like oh my god
excuse happening like their assignments
were like no one was like it would take
eight seconds I'm like waiting for
someone to but like it was just not
happening so it's like oh there's eight
seconds I'm like waiting and my squad is
not filling up I thought it loaded you I
can skip it not skip it but I know that
it did do a thing where like it's still
low degree so I think the officers have
that it supplies you little flashbang
yeah
nice [ __ ]
oh there are a lot of guys there I'm
gonna go back that's from the slither
man
we'll wait keep saying we'll get it
we're gonna get it it'd be cool if we
got it good really tie the stream
together here we go was that a lot of us
first person here playing still are
still a man
also over here dude bum go rocket
barrage uh Jebus man rob was playing
quite a bit of officer earlier flaming
cuz it's more like a team player thing
at that point right this guy this guy's
like wait I can't snipe two of these
guys Boba Fett uh-oh I'm [ __ ] I can't
play it was Boba Fett that's fine you
can play as Han or Ray Ray has a cool
ability she can screw with enemies
controls so everything is like inverted
and opposite cause yeah
Daniel X milk Tex wants to know or wants
to ask can you explain the rank run
system and this is dope by the way the
ranking system like how you rank up it's
just experience so the more I play as a
class I'll get the more ranks like I'll
get a higher rank and then that
that essentially will allow me to oh
[ __ ] that's a mobile phone with that
yeah oh [ __ ] I can't they came from
behind as well yeah how many more do
they need so yeah you like you know you
the more you rank you get the ability to
unlock weapons and star card slots
look at this
oh no okay Oh balls out Oh Ben Boba Fett
yeah no wait
you need five thousand I don't know what
you're at three thousand it's probably
not gonna happen
yeah blew it I'll get better at this
game you get next stream we do I'll be
hella good dude okay I'll be so good
just rollin
nice uh-oh is that
Oh
Oh turning on that was horrible and
Darth Maul looky-looky it up oh that's
what I forgot robbed the Wookiee mess
they want a jet trooper well either way
I think this do you play the other side
what happens here yeah you go back and
forth well let you finish this next side
here that's why do you want to do arcade
you can try it go for it see if that
works
is that a cap ten yeah it looks like cap
is ten currently that makes sense that's
what the last slot you get was that my
overall like big feet NZ it's like it's
like almost 12 hours from now I was
totally wrong look um say one player
what I have I mean I technically I have
a controller and like you could play no
but on the back oh it did say one you
say oh one player so maybe it was just
at that event
alright alright well let's let's see
this do it I've not done this like them
exciting wiped them out I've sent a get
my apprentice Darth Maul
the people turn light music oh my god
best song
[Music]
that's loud I love it
oh you're do you have a timer by the way
Rob so you gotta kill those guys to get
this is cool so nicely at least like fly
out a hero figure it out because I'm
like whoa there you go okay
oh thanks bro Cameron thanks for having
her back
fourth choke choke three guys though I
know right that's sick pretty impressive
I gonna win this one again
oh listen do the whole wind up
oh it just continues from where you're
at I faded this music that part I know
right do the whole track get the license
[Music]
I kind of at least it takes two hits to
kill someone he asked it does it can I
block a ricochet yeah Oh God Porsche I
suck just not used to your powers yet
you have to throw the long way
should be a close one for left or left
to do one more yeah okay I'm still going
right [ __ ] keep forgetting that's boring
our force choke hold Reaper surprise oh
yeah right at the end of it I'm hella
good I hope you only get one star man
remember do you remember the first
trailer for episode 1 it's a pretty cool
trailer just like all double lightsaber
all where did I go that's kind of neat
you see that there was like yeah it's a
graduate Roger graduating Chris a wants
to know do the games last about 10
minutes by timer if they do I won't be
buying it's not just my timer it's like
if you win the objective you could win
in like less than two minutes which is
what happened one time for us ready
woman download this you need origin Jake
it might be show up for you yet because
maybe open beta preload doesn't happen
till 1:00 a.m. Pacific
some pie always notices bro dad
this is actually a decent way to
practice I think so too
yeah even with these weapons ring this
thing is whenever I pick a new class
like you know starting off this bait I
was like oh I like consistently like
looking at the menus to like understand
the abilities because look it's they're
just symbols on my head oh [ __ ]
Payton or onion yes if you plays in a
way you can't play
[Music]
viewing gets no respect
it's weird when they crouch used to that
I'm tired
wait I thought you got it
I look like
they know your robot hands could get
burned sure do you see angry mode yeah I
wish to look like a class like I had the
heavy class head like I'd be so low P I
just I miss having a rock of her not
having a rock launcher I don't know had
it always yeah like a grenade launcher I
think that's a star Cartman
yeah probably I think actually it is
called barrage Oh Dan you got really
gift when you mess up you're really not
this way
guys honey
I wish I was this good in the online a
man selling yourself short you guys have
any last questions to send them in
because I think we're gonna wrap it up
after he go some more these plums plums
bone trooper number three one seven
seven forty remaining now I'm confused
and then just say ten if I was like 40
of your troops oh maybe that makes more
sense
you're right come on Rob do or die
we're chilling just a first person
yep Phil Elliot thanks for stopping by
enjoy your time with cuphead if it
induces some rage far away one kill
could be yours good job and that's all
she wrote that is all she wrote Rob
pretty good stuff pretty good stuff we
had a little bit of a hiccup in that
intro that's what happens yeah so we
made up we made up for it thanks
everyone for tuning in
that was battlefront 2 early access beta
as mentioned if you pre-ordered it you
should have it already and or are
playing it open bid is tomorrow 1:00
a.m. Pacific 4:00 a.m. Eastern that's
roughly 12 hours from now if you're not
in those time zones come back tomorrow
we'll be live again at 11:00
I haven't actually decided the game
tomorrow maybe I'll just have Rob play
more battlefront oh really that may be
for for a nice happy Friday a happy
Friday stream but until then have a
happy Thursday and see you guys next
time see you guys peace out peace
[Music]
you